so good morning my name is mike oras
taglio i'm executive director of yale
climate energy institute and i would
like to introduce the director mark
pagani professor of paleo climatology at
Yale University who will say a few words
to welcome you to our conference mark
all right hello folks I don't want to
take up too much your time here what I
do want to welcome you to a conference
and I do hope we all learn something so
I'm a climate scientist I suppose and
I'm deeply entrenched and you know the
history of climate in the past and also
projections for the future and if you're
following the science of climate you'd
know that in the next hundred years were
projected to reach co2 levels not seen
for the last 50 million years 50 million
years ago we like to refer to the earth
as experiencing a super greenhouse
climate that's a climate where they're
subtropical and tropical flora you know
ecosystems at the poles and there's palm
trees on it antartica you know we're not
going to get there that quickly but
that's where we're headed okay without
question co2 is the most important
greenhouse gas on earth and it has a
tremendously long half-life
extraordinary thousands to tens of
thousands a years whatever we put into
the atmosphere today will last for
thousands to tens of thousands of years
and coal based energy production is
contributes to hundreds and thousands
hundreds of thousands of deaths globally
as estimated by the World Health
Organization so for me co2 really is the
enemy and anything that lowers the rate
of co2 emissions and contributes to co2
free energy should be a priority
globally nuclear produces about eleven
percent of electricity and in the US
it's nineteen percent it's already an
important part of the climate solution
but it's also very taboo and certainly
around my dinner table okay
but how much of the discussion on
nuclear energy around the dinner table
is based on outdated information
mythology and poor information regarding
our options is it's important to discuss
so the goal the conference is to have
mature conversation on new technologies
the existing problems and possible
solutions and perhaps a vision forward
so again I hope we all learned something
from this today one last thing the
conference was spearheaded by two
members of the Yale community professor
yahia Khalil and an undergraduate
student Jared Milford now kahile is a
professor chemical engineering he was
recently appointed as chairman and
operating agent for the hydrogen safety
task of the International Energy Agency
he was part of the US nuclear risk
assessment teams that developed accident
management guidelines to address
vulnerabilities of the US nuclear fleet
after the 1979 three mile island
accident but in some ways more
interesting the conference really began
with Jared milford he's an undergraduate
as I said when he came to my office
discuss nuclear energy he majors in
ethics politics and economics and he's
really the lead organizer today's
conference I'm sure you all the
participants have interacted with him
quite a bit he's worked at the Brookings
Institution on energy and climate policy
and it's been a fellow at Yale's
Institute for Social and Policy Studies
and before coming to Yale he worked at
the read research reactor in Portland
Oregon where at age 17 he became the
youngest license nuclear reactor
operator in the nation now I don't know
what you were doing at 17 I know what I
was doing at 17 and it didn't it didn't
come close to that yeah so with that
Michael come on back up and introduce
the game rules here and there for a
second oh so mark is an academic climate
scientist I'm from the energy industry
can't tell the difference and it and we
work through our or I'm at an Energy
Institute yeah okay okay so we will
start the agenda with the opening
address on climate change and the urgent
need for
abundant carbon-free energy Jim Hansen
who is the director of the climates of
the program on climate science awareness
and solutions at Columbia University
wanted to be here for this talk at the
last moment literally something came up
that a crock required him to be
elsewhere he sends his regrets but more
important he sends his deputy director
so I would like to introduce dr. push
Kirk arrecha who has kindly agreed to
give the talk on Jim's behalf dr.
caretta is a climate scientist himself
he worked for several years at the NASA
Goddard Institute for Space Studies
where he has worked on climate modeling
in particular the interaction between
human influence and climate and he
continues that work as the deputy
director of the program on climate
science awareness and solutions at
Columbia University's Earth Institute so
please welcome dr. push go yeah you can
click on a few boards advanced all right
so thanks a lot Mike and Jarrod and the
other organizers for allowing
accommodating this last-minute
substitution as Mike said Jim sends his
sincere apologies and I'm also sorry
that for those of you who were expecting
to talk with him or were excited to see
him hopefully at least the message will
still be more or less the same I didn't
have much time to prepare for this but
luckily as some of you might know almost
exactly two weeks ago we held a very
similar meeting one day meeting at
Columbia it was under the auspices of
the UN sustainable development solutions
network and I was the lead scientific
organizer that so and Jim and I both
gave talks there so what I'll be
presenting here today is more or less
say
a hybrid version of what of both his and
my talks so alright so I'm just going to
cover two broad topics since this is a
general audience I'm going to run
through briefly the causes and effects
and remedies of recent climate change
and the historical and potential future
role of nuclear and mitigating climate
change and air pollution okay so when I
give talks about climate change I
usually like to cover three key aspects
first of all they're loosely modeled
after three working groups of the IPCC
first how do we know climate is changing
and that humans are mostly responsible
at second why should we care in other
words what are the likely impacts of
unabated climate change and third what
can we do about it and what's the
required timeframe okay let's start with
the global mean surface temperature data
and I'm sure most of you have seen these
types of graphs so I won't go into too
many details about them but basically
the time series up at the top tell us
that most of the global surface
temperature change over the entire
industrial era has occurred in the last
few decades and the spatial data shown
here show tell tell us that the polar
regions have warmed the most and that
the land regions have warmed more than
the ocean the northern hemisphere has
warm more than the southern hemisphere
and so on we also know that nighttime
temperatures have increased faster than
daytime temperatures and lastly we we
also know from satellite measurements
that troposphere tropospheric
temperatures have increased while
stratospheric temperatures of decreased
tapas fear is the lowest layer
stratosphere is the next lowest layer
and this is all fully expected from
theory now there's been a lot of
attention recently on the the slowdown
in the rate of global surface warming
over the last 15 years and now you often
hear this invoked usually by climate
change deniers and minimizer's as
evidence of the
so notion that climate change stopped in
1998 that's immediately falsified by
recognizing a few basic facts first of
all keep in mind that this is only one
line of evidence that's not even the
most important one actually second of
all a much more useful insight into the
problem is gleam when we look at the
planetary energy imbalance so planetary
it's defined as the difference between
the absorbed radiation and the outgoing
radiation to space and it affects all
components of the climate system so they
not just the air as shown in the
previous figure but the land of the open
most importantly the ocean and when you
do the type of analysis we did a few
years ago and many other groups have
done similar analyses we all find that
over ninety percent of the overall
climate system heating has taken place
in the ocean and that's again fully
expected from theory because of a very
large thermal inertia of the ocean and
we also know that the imbalance was
significant and it persisted even during
the period of the most recent prolonged
unusually prolonged solar minimum which
is highlighted here so this combined
with other lines of evidence that i
won't go into tell us very strongly that
the Sun cannot be the primary cause of
the recent energy imbalance and
therefore recent global warming and now
there's also important in direct lines
of evidence of global warming oops and
probably the most important category of
evidence is that is the net loss of ice
around the world now this figure shows
the net mass loss from the two great ice
sheets Greenland and Antarctica and when
you do the when you look at the numbers
it's several it adds up to several
hundred giga tons of ice per year over
the last decade or so combined over the
2i sheets and this amounts to about a
third of recent global sea-level rise
and that is very significant and very
troubling because
the most vulnerable parts of these two
ice sheets if they fully disintegrate
they could amount to about 10 meters of
global sea-level rise and as Mark was
saying we to get back to a planet like
that is basically just a completely
different state complete different point
in time it's like we'd be living on a
different planet not to mention the
massive massive coastal disruptions
around the world and so on so the bottom
line again i glossed over tons and tons
of material but as far as causation the
observed rate magnitude and spatial
patterns of recent climate system
warming overall climate system warming
not just the surface not just the land
and so on along with well-established
scientific principles which is really
what we mean by theory and science as
opposed to theory and law is more of a
speculative term but combined with
results from climate models they allow
us to rule out natural factors and they
show that the enhanced greenhouse effect
is actually the prime by far the most
important driver of climate change in at
least the last 50 years yes this thing
just has a mind of its own Asics keeps
going up which is fine but so so given
that we the next question is what what
is the cause of the enhanced greenhouse
effect well multiple lines of a very
strong scientific evidence show that
human activities most most importantly
fossil fuel burning secondarily land use
have are responsible fully responsible
for the rise in co2 and other greenhouse
gases over the industrial era so for
bitter or better or worse we basically
now control the fate of the Earth's
climate so taking a closer look at
fossil fuels so the figure on the Left
shows total primary energy supply by
source and you can see that over the
past several decades fossil fuels remain
by far the dominant source of global
energy supply they account for about
eighty percent of global energy and on
the right here is a figure showing
fossil fuel co2 emissions over the
industrial era and we
that despite the impressive growth of
renewables and nuclear in some countries
ways co2 emissions are continuing to
rise exponentially in the last decade
for instance they've risen by about
three percent per year and so the upshot
of all this is that the fossil fuel use
is responsible for about eighty percent
of the atmospheric co2 rise remember the
other component is land use so what are
the consequences that we've already seen
from human induced climate change well
one of one of the big ones is sea level
rise and this is very important because
this is essentially irreversible on
millennial timescales in other words
what we're seeing is the sea levels now
are going to be the baseline sea levels
for millennia into the future so the
right what this figure shows is that the
rise in the last twenty years which is
the period of most reliable data this is
mostly gleaned from satellite data the
rate of sea level rise is more than
double the rate over the previous sixty
years and it's more than five times the
rate of the early 20th century so sea
level rise is accelerating and a higher
sea level among other things it means
more damaging storm surge as we witness
on here on the East Coast with hurricane
sandy we're also seeing in terms of
consequences of a worsening of extreme
events extreme climate related events in
various parts of the world these include
heat waves wild fires and storms
droughts and especially here in the US
increased frequency and intensity of
heavy downpours and floods okay so
what about the future well alright so in
terms of sea level rise a good place to
seek guidance is the Earth's history so
if we look at the previous interglacial
which was the e Mian interglacial was
about 120,000 years ago the global
average sea level was between five to
nine meters higher than it is today
remember a meters just over three feet
so and that was when the temperature is
was at most two degrees Celsius above
pre-industrial so that's very important
to bear in mind when you hear discussion
which you will especially come as we get
closer to December of the Paris your
framework convention talks two degrees
Celsius is by no means a guarantee of
safety in fact Jim and I and a growing
number of colleagues are calling on the
community to scientific community to to
be more outspoken in saying that we're
not in there is not a scientific
consensus about 2 degrees Celsius that's
more or less a political number and as
far as what would happen if we go beyond
32 degrees houses just say three or four
degrees Celsius above pre-industrial
which is where we're headed or even
worse we look back to the pliocene epoch
and that was several million years ago
and we see that the sea level that time
was about 15 to 25 meters higher and so
either one of these even the low-end
relatively low end even one meter of sea
level rise it would be very disruptive
to coastal communities around the world
and when we're talking about these
levels I mean there will be massive
disruptions to coastal human communities
and ecosystems including in very
populous areas and it would disrupt at
the very least hundreds of millions of
people's lives okay what about another
irreversible impact of human induced
climate change which is species
extinction this is a good nice figure I
like this I've been using us for a few
years even though it's from the previous
IPCC report I came out in 2007
recent one i haven't seen a similar
figure like this so and the ipcc was if
you like a little bolder with this
figure in saying that sustained warming
of as little as one and a half degrees
celsius above pre-industrial could
commit over up to thirty percent of the
world species to extinction and if we go
again 23 degrees celsius above
pre-industrial up to half of the world
species would be and this is verbatim
committed to extinction okay so that
sort of ends the doom and gloom portion
of the talk out there is a bright side
to all this namely we know how to get
out of the crisis and the root cause as
i mentioned the eighty percent of the
cost is fossil fuels and why is that the
case well they're the cheapest energy
and the reason for that is simply is
basically twofold they're heavily
subsidized to the tune of half a
trillion dollars a year of globally and
their true costs in terms of human
health and environmental impacts and so
on are completely externalized and so
the way the remedy for that is to put
enact a rising price on carbon emissions
so that's the fundamental requirement
but we also need other things to help us
along namely improve regulations direct
enci vehicle efficiency building
efficiency and so on and also technology
RD&D finally a personal and individual
actions these are the things we often
hear about you know driving more
fuel-efficient cars switching to a
compact for less fluorescent light bulbs
eating fewer animal products and so on
all that stuff will help but it's it's
far from sufficient so we this really
has to be solved within an international
policy framework okay so what does all
this mean in terms of fossil fuel use
this figure shows the amount of fossil
fuels coal oil and natural gas that
we've burned so far over the industrial
era that's the regions in purple and the
regions in blue and yellow are the
amounts remaining
and that you can see that the amounts
burned so far amount to a tiny fraction
of what's potentially usable and in fact
a recent assessments like the one shown
here this is something I compiled for a
recent paper of ours they reveal that
potentially usable fossil fuel resources
contain dozens of times the amount of
carbon in the atmosphere so if we burn
even a significant fraction any
significant fraction of the remaining
especially coal or unconventional oil or
gas we're in deep trouble as Mark
mentioned among other reasons because
co2 has a multi millennial lifetime in
the atmosphere so this implies that the
remaining fuels again especially kool
and the unconventional fuels must not be
burned unless sir the resulting co2
emissions are captured and sequestered
but unfortunately that the technology to
do that is still in its infancy and so
it's unlikely to make a significant dent
in the near term and the relevant time
very so again on the bright side that
there are good examples of rapid
emissions reductions even in high energy
using countries so for instance in a in
a single decade in late 70s the late 80s
France increased its nuclear power
output by a factor of 15 and the that
resulted in the poor the fraction of its
nuclear of its electricity comes from
nuclear increasing from eight percent to
about seventy percent and similarly in
Germany over the past 15 years or so
we've seen a significant increase in the
share of electricity from solar and wind
and a slight decrease in fossil fuel
share of electricity and they've also
have the share of electricity from
nuclear that's not necessarily a good or
bad thing by itself but the problem has
its come the problems arisen in the last
few years because they decided after
Fukushima I'll get into more details
about this later but to rapidly phase
out some of their nuclear power plants
and that's led to an increase in their
colon
shins in the last couple years okay so
on to focus on nuclear power as a
mitigation option so here I'm mainly
going to be talking about Dave so one
wants me to rush I guess ok so here I'm
going to be talking about a
peer-reviewed scientific paper that i
published with Jim a couple years ago in
the journal environmental science and
technology and I got the idea for this
paper after witnessing the widespread
backlash against nuclear after Fukushima
which occurred in March 2011 given the
extensive focus on the drawbacks of this
energy source I wanted to conduct a a
big picture objective long-term analysis
of its potential benefits in terms of
human health and climate so okay so for
starters immediate we have to
acknowledge that again being objective
like all there is no perfect energy
source nuclear has its pros and cons but
because it supplies a significant
fraction of world electricity it's de
facto a very important low-carbon lobe
air pollution energy source so to
conduct our analysis we started with a
simple thought experiment what if
nuclear-power never existed what energy
sources would have replaced it and what
are the implications of that replacement
so we looked at several different
spatial scales besides the world as a
whole we also looked at OE CD europe
which in this case includes 13 countries
and the recent top 5 co2 emitting
countries and together the sub global
regions we analyzed account for about
ninety percent of world nuclear energy
production we also looked at two
different time periods the historical
period but which covers about 40 years
in the projection period from twenty ten
to twenty fifty so too would
all right so--okay so it for the
historical period we need to start with
several pieces of information to address
this thought experiment quantitatively
so we started with the annual nuclear
energy production data these are data
from the IAEA the nuclear production
numbers are shown in red here and we
devised a capacity factor based
substitution scenario where capacity
factor is defined as the ratio of actual
power output to the theoretical output
for whatever electricity generating
device you're talking about whether it's
a wind turbine a nuclear reactor and so
on I won't get into the details but so
on a global basis this gives us about
ninety-five percent replacement of
historical nuclear by coal and the
remainder by gas and this this level of
substitute substitution by coal is fully
plausible for basically the same reasons
Cole has been by far historically the
largest source of electricity namely its
low fuel and total production costs its
high capacity and high capacity factor
and very importantly the fact that it's
a widespread and abundant resource you
can see the curve for Cole here is far
greater than any of the other curves
right so for the projection period we
started with a slightly different data
we took the range of annual nuclear
energy production from the an expert
assessment conducted by the
International Atomic Energy Agency and
as this assessment doesn't count for the
effects of Fukushima on energy choices
so the high end curves shown here
reflect aggressive climate mitigation
policies and the low end assume
essentially none the subsidy the choice
of substitution scenario in this case is
a bit more complicated unlike with the
historical case hi capacitive that could
replace nuclear besides just
or besides most likely call namely
high-capacity advanced high capacity
factor gas plants which can act as base
load power plants and possibly some
types of renewables for instance
concentrated solar power plants with
large-scale thermal storage so these
other energy sources have also become
more competitive with coal as in terms
of base load power and to simplify these
complexities we we just decided to do a
bounding analysis where we looked at two
extreme cases one in which all projected
nuclear is all of this all of these new
clearance I'll use are replaced by coal
and the other in which it's all replaced
by gas and so again because there are
other alternative replacements that we
could have looked at for instance
renewables which wouldn't yell did too
much interesting because they have more
or less similar mortality and emission
factors as nuclear and in any case the
our results for the projection period
should be regarded as upper and lower
limits okay so to do to the actual
calculations we use the following the
published peer-reviewed mortality and
greenhouse gas emission factors shown
here and these are defined in terms of
the deaths and emissions per unit
electric energy produced and they I
wanted to stress that these values all
reflect impacts over the entire life
cycle for each fuel source so that
includes fuel mining transport waste
disposal plant construction and so on
and except as noted for China the
mortality factors are and the emission
factors actually are based on analysis
of developed countries and the mortality
factor is shown here I reflect the sum
of deaths from occupational accidents
and air pollution related deaths so in
the case of nuclear for instance air
pollution related deaths implies deaths
from radiation fallout so just looking
at these numbers alone it's it becomes
immediately clear that per unit electric
energy a nuclear causes 400 times fewer
fatalities
and 16 times lower greenhouse gas
emissions in coal and about 40 times
lower fatalities and nine times fewer
greenhouse gas emissions and natural gas
and our emission factors are a few years
old now but they're still fully
consistent with the range of emission
factor is given by the in the latest
IPCC report which is shown here so you
can see from here that the values from
nuclear again this is greenhouse gas
emissions per unit electric energy
produced the values for nuclear are
broadly similar to the values for the
non-hydro renewables so finally using
all this information to do the actual
computation of net prevented impacts by
nuclear we looked at for each year of
each substitution scenario we calculated
the prevented impacts as the difference
between the impacts caused by the
replacement fossil fuel and the impacts
caused directly by nuclear itself so
what we find is pretty staggering
especially in terms of prevented
mortality so this figure shows a
prevented mortality net prevented deaths
for both the historical and the
projection periods for all the regions
that we looked at and what we find is
that in the historical period nuclear
prevented an average of about 2 million
deaths globally and over half a million
deaths again these are cumulative net
deaths prevented over half a million
deaths in each of the of Europe and us
us and over 150,000 deaths in the former
Soviet Union and Japan and in the
projection period the numbers are even
more staggering we find that on the
global scale nuclear depending on which
fuel replaces it could prevent between
400,000 and up 7 million deaths out to
2050 and I should point out that these
on these mortality numbers there's a
significant error bar and this reflects
the ninety-five percent confidence
interval of the mortality factors that
we used and it's roughly a factor for
above and
a factor of four from the mean also I
haven't shown this here but we also
looked at prevented serious illnesses
and the numbers aren't too important to
show here because they're basically a
factor of 10 higher than these so
nuclear has clearly contributed hugely
in terms of prevented mortality and
prevented morbidity so this figure shows
the results for prevent mortality on an
annual basis so we see from here that in
the last in the previous decade nuclear
on on average globally prevented too
close to 80 thousand deaths per year and
over 20,000 deaths a year in Europe and
the US and several thousand in the other
regions we looked at ok so our results
for prevented greenhouse gas emissions
are equally stunning we find that in s
in the historical period which is shown
in the top bar graph here on a global
scale nuclear prevented on an average of
about 64 billion tons of co2 equivalent
emissions globally and that's equal
that's massive that is equivalent to the
co2 emissions output of several hundred
coal-fired large coal-fired power plants
or to put it another way it's equivalent
to the cumulative co2 emissions from the
past 35 years of coal burning in the US
over the past 17 years of coal burning
in China and the projection period again
the numbers are even more impressive
because nuclear could again depending on
which fuel it places on the global scale
it could displace up to 80 to 240
billion tons of co2 equivalent emissions
right so as with any theoretical
analysis it's useful to compare to the
real world when possible so let's do
that for mortality so for reference our
calculations give us almost 5,000 deaths
cumulatively caused by nuclear in this
historical period
this is significant but it's still
several hundred times lower than the our
calculations for prevented yes and what
about the empirical data what can we
tell from those well we analyzed each of
the three major nuclear accidents
starting with Three Mile Island which
was in March 1979 and we find that there
have been through a number of
investigations very thorough scientific
by both federal and state agencies and
independent academic groups and they all
come to more or less the same conclusion
namely that there is no significant
radiological impact from Three Mile
Island to either people or the
environment for instance here's a study
that looks at it was a 20-year follow-up
study looking at a cohort of over 30,000
people are affected and they found no
attributable deaths due to cancer from
the radiation fallout now what about
Chernobyl that's the most controversial
one because it's the only accident in
the 50-plus years of nuclear commercial
utility-scale nuclear power generation
that has led to a scientifically
attributable fatalities due to radiation
fallout and the most by far the most
comprehensive authoritative scientific
assessment i found to this is the 2008
unscary report so unscared the UN
Scientific Committee on the effects of
atomic radiation and their much like the
IPCC and that they conducted a critical
synthesis and an review of peer-reviewed
droves of peer-reviewed scientific
sources and they analyzed 20 years of
data for various illnesses they find in
terms of mortality is that 28 first
responders died within a few months of
the accident and those deaths were
directly attributable to radiation
because their acute radiation sickness
and a further 15 deaths occurred because
of thyroid cancer which again is
attributable to radiation fallout and
that those 15 deaths from thyroid cancer
were out of 6,000 diagnosed cases so the
actual incidence of deaths from thyroid
cancer and this is not to diminish the
suffering of any other side
cancer obviously but but the fact is
it's a highly treatable disease other
than that the assessment found possibly
elevated rates of leukemia and cataracts
in a small relatively small fraction of
the several hundred thousand recovery
workers other otherwise they found no
persuasive evidence of any other health
effects due to radiation fallout from
the accidents except a psychological
trauma this includes stress fear of
radiation so on and that is significant
that has changed the quality of life for
many of the residents there furthermore
the authors chose not to quantify
projected deaths because of what they
considered unacceptable levels of
uncertainties in the predictions so when
you hear figures like there's likely to
be tens of thousands or even hundreds of
thousands of deaths in the future from
Chernobyl it should be highly skeptical
skeptical because there it's very
difficult to quantify those meaningfully
and to convey all the uncertainties in
the predictions that are used to derive
them okay in terms of ecological impacts
the International Atomic Energy Agency
in 2006 conducted an assessment that
found that they are worst in the initial
few weeks after a few years after the
accident but even then they were mostly
isolated to what's now the Chernobyl
exclusion zone which is a 30-kilometer
radius around the plant but
fast-forwarding to recent recent history
the biota there including within just a
few kilometers of the plant is
flourishing and part of the reason
ironically is because the evacuation of
all the humans so as far as the aquatic
ecosystems contamination of water bodies
was worst within the first few weeks
after the accident but now the only
concern remaining is are a few isolated
lake systems okay what about a fukushima
which is the most recent accident
unsecured again conducted an assessment
this accident and it published the
reports almost exactly a year ago this
this report reflects the scientific
consensus of over 80 technical experts
from 18 different countries and I won't
get into
details but the upshot is they found as
with Three Mile Island no significant
observed or expected impacts for humans
or ecosystems except a theoretically
increased risk of thyroid cancer among
the children who are the most exposed
all right what about comparison to
empirical data with respect to
greenhouse gas emissions this figure
shows it's a little busy but it shows
the electricity production by for select
sources in Japan and Germany over the
last 20 years and I highlight these two
countries because they made decisions
directly after Fukushima that affected
their nuclear power output namely they
phase down there a significant number of
their nuclear reactors in the case of
Japan you can see nuclear which is the
blue curve here plummeted to near zero
and that's understandable but in Germany
nuclear all they also decided to phase
down the nuclear blast slightly less
amount so the upshot of this is that in
the years since Fukushima emissions from
our excuse me generation of electricity
from fossil fuel sources has increased
significantly in both these countries so
in Japan fossil fuels coal and gas shown
here amount to about seventy percent of
electricity generation and in Germany
coal amounts to about half of the
electricity almost half of electricity
generation whereas renewables while they
have shown an impressive increase the
renewables in Germany other dashed line
here since Fukushima they've increased
marginally but it appears that the
increase went mostly in replacing gas
with decrease common Utley and then
despite all that we hear about Germany
and it is impressive but the fact is on
an annual basis which is it's important
to integrate out the noise that we see
so in other words we see we hear a lot
about we hear a lot of headlines and so
on about germany in the summer
generating upwards of half of its
electricity from solar and wind and so
on but what really matters is the longer
term generation and when you look at it
in that sense it's
solar and wind combined in Germany in
2013 accounted for just under 14 percent
of total electricity production whereas
again Cole still remains dominant by far
and so the upshot of this with respect
to greenhouse gas emissions is that
since Fukushima emissions and co2
emissions in Japan have increased by
seven percent in the year after
Fukushima and then they remained at that
level in 2013 and in Germany they
increased by three percent in 2013 and
another 2% in 2012 these might not seem
like large numbers but to put them in
perspective the co2 emission the global
co2 emissions increase over the last
decade has been about three percent per
year so these are significant increases
all right so I think I'm running out of
time but basically we acknowledge in our
paper you can read there for more
details but that there are various
uncertainties and limitations to our
study as with any scientific analysis
they mainly stem from the fact that our
mortality and emission factors are time
invariant and they also don't reflect
the reflect the substantial disparities
between developed and developing
countries nor do they reflect the
impacts of ongoing climate change in
case of the emission factors okay so to
summarize significant problems obviously
remain with the current generation of
nuclear power but it has clearly made
major contributions to mitigation of
human-caused climate change as well as
air pollution which by the way I didn't
mention it but I think we heard some
statistics earlier from the World Health
Organization but the latest estimate
actually puts the number globally for
outdoor ambient air pollution related
deaths globally is about oh it's almost
four million and about a million of
those occurred in China alone so air
pollution is a massive problem along
with climate change so nuclear in the
historical period nuclear is likely
prevented hundreds of thousands of times
more deaths and 15 times more greenhouse
gas emissions than it's caused
and in the next few decades it could
prevent to millions of additional deaths
and hundreds of billions of tons of
emissions if it replaces coal and as a
sort of corollary to our assessment we
find that large-scale expansion of a
natural gas if it's unconstrained
meaning if the result teeny emissions
aren't captor and sequestered it would
cause far more deaths and greenhouse gas
emissions than a similar expansion of
nuclear power and that's stem simply
from the higher impacts per unit energy
that I discussed earlier okay thanks